stay Monday they how hard it is to
explain things de belem talking about
time well I saw but I haven't looked at
our voids hello everyone we're here
again today's is another lecture another
day and I'm gonna do a brief hopefully
brief I sometimes I don't get to do it
so briefly my son criticizes me quite a
bit about that and yeah I a sometimes
you got to go into detail but I'm gonna
try to do a brief recap okay recap of
what we did these last few days and
where we stand and you know what what
we're going to be discussing today what
we've been discussing lately and the
main point that I want to make is that
mathematical physics is irrational okay
now until you define some of these terms
and search for criteria that's a cheap
shot you say oh you say that because you
don't like it or because you don't like
math or you don't know math okay so
people go into all those you know
different paths to try to criticize what
you're doing fine so then let's define
what we mean by irrational why I am
accusing mathematical physics both
quantum mechanics and general relativity
you can include string theory in there
as well why they're irrational okay and
the main point there and here I'll put
the criteria up so that we have
something intelligent to talk about
there's a criteria the first one
converting concepts into physical
objects you say the word particle and
you say well are you referring to a
corpuscle which is what norm normal
people refer you know think of when they
when you say particle and they say well
no not really what we're referring to is
to a wavefunction
or to a probability wave or a field that
extends all the way to the edge of the
universe and and so those are concepts
and what these people are doing
converting them into physical objects
and then they start moving them around
they say oh I transfer
energy how can you transfer energy of an
active energy is a concept how can you
move a massive mass as a concept
how can you dilate time if time is not a
physical object it's a concept and so on
down the line and people say well you're
nitpicking on the on the semantics
you're just doing semantics well you
know maybe it's the other way around
maybe the people who are doing semantics
are the people who are saying that
they're transferring energy what did
they really mean what did they transfer
I mean if we're gonna talk physics we
can't be moving concepts around that's
the first criterion the second criterion
let me put it back up again here the
second criterion is that you use
undefined words or you use them in
consistently throughout your
dissertation you know you say that
space-time is an object and you say okay
so what do you mean by object what is an
object and the person says well an
object's is that which you can see or
touch well can you see or touch
space-time and that's where you know
there it breaks down and so they do have
to define these key terms otherwise
we're gonna use them and consistently
and then you have you know the fact that
the the theory you know has to follow
from the assumptions if you present a
knife you can't talk and say that you
know the crime was committed by poison
and so on down the line and I've added
one lady that says that you know when
you describe and you claim to have
explained something and you know that
that last criteria describing and
claimed to have explained that's
pertinent when you deal with magnets you
will find all kinds of people specially
in YouTube saying how a magnet works
insinuating that they're going to give
you the mechanism the cause of how a
magnet you know or how mother nature
does their invisible work and that's
what that not what they do they describe
they say look positive attracts negative
that's one answer that you'll see
another answer is that the most popular
lately is that the electrons you know in
the atoms of each of the
magnets the electrons are spinning in
the same direction and you say okay so
the electrons are of this atom here is
spinning in a clockwise spewed from the
top and this one is also spinning
clockwise how does that produce
attraction between the magnets and what
it is is a description turned into an
explanation they're saying look every
time we measure or we detect or we use
our whatever you know are invisible eyes
or the ability to be invisible
see invisibly or invisible things we
notice that you know that every time
there's attraction the electrons you
know spin clockwise in this atom in and
this atom well that's a description you
still haven't explained how that the
fact that they both spin in the same
direction produces attraction in fact
you can't you can't explain with
particles with discrete particles any
kind of attraction and that's really one
of the biggest problems that
mathematical physics has you cannot
produce the force of pull using
particles and that's why they invented
the concept field that's why they talk
about a probability wave that extends
infinitely and so that's when they try
to kind of say well you know we covered
the entire universe and from there we
can more or less tell you how a magnet
attracts another or how a gluon and
compels to quartz to come together etc
etc etc so these are descriptions turned
into explanations that's all they are
and that's not a real mechanism and so
the issue now comes are these irrational
criteria or the criteria we used to
define irrationality are these objective
or are they subjective you know someone
may say well you know you created these
criteria to defend your religion your to
push your agenda fine and here they are
again and let's just look at one of them
the first one
and we're saying okay what's wrong with
them with claiming that a theory is a
Nash irrational if it converts abstract
concept into physical objects if you
convert love into a physical thing and
say well love moves mountains is that a
valid physical theory can we say that
can we say that love moves mountains
people will all understand that that's a
metaphor that that's a figure of speech
that's good for poetry you can say oh
love moving mountains beautiful love it
can we say can we use that literally in
physics and the answers definitely no so
this is a valid criteria to define what
as is an irrational theory and so now
the the skeptic or the devil's advocate
or the religious opponent as I call them
you know they can they have the option
they say okay let me challenge that fine
come bring it on what do you have and
what are they gonna bring up against
using a concept as an object they can't
and eight and why would they reject it
what's their argument what's their
justification for rejecting this
criterion and if they can't reject it I
don't care if they include something
else they might say look I think we
should also include such an such thing
that's fine let's discuss that but I
don't see any reason why they can reject
this one and the only reason to reject
this one is well I don't like it I don't
believe in it and it destroys my
religion that's the only reason
ultimately and so yes I had to create
this criteria to find out what is
rational and the reason for that the
reason behind that is that we need to
establish you know if science is
rational exploration we do need to
define not only what an explanation is
but what is rational the interesting
thing is you kind of don't have to
define rational or irrational in that
sense because regardless of the word you
use to bunch up these four conditions
it has these four conditions regardless
if you cook you don't have to use the
word irrational you can use the word dog
okay I'm gonna call the word dog Sanchez
know anything that has these four
conditions is dog you could use anything
okay I'm saying the word it is
irrational is irrelevant the word is the
route that you use that basically says
it has these four conditions is
irrelevant you can use any words
irrational might just confuse the issue
because then they go because you're just
redefining irrational so in a sense it's
it's it's a bit may be misleading in
that sense or or confusing not
misleading it's confusing because y-you
just just the way people normally think
they can change but we're I'm saying in
a way I mean again that's what we're
trying to change this I'm not saying
it's it's dumb by any means but or in
vain or anything that's besides the
point I'm just saying that regardless of
what word you use as the as the
qualifier all the fire for these four
conditions I'm at these four conditions
I'm going to bunch them up into a word
just for shorthand essentially okay okay
you could say science or their theory is
a you know cherchez all those nations
which are a or any explanations I'm
saying you could you I'm saying it's
essentially shorthand you're essentially
saying your theory has has these four
conditions that's that's all you're
really saying I'm defining you can use
any word yes no it's not that you're
redefine I mean yeah that's why I can
the the word irrational rational just
kind of confuses the issue because your
lens
no no because people have their
preconceived notions and they're trying
to change but it's just it's just it
says if you you use these four
conditions for the word god and then you
started using God so yeah okay you can
use any word but it's just like the word
you choose does confuse the issue if you
choose a specific word well again I
think the only reason someone would
object to the word rational or
irrational
is that they feel that you're offending
them yeah because what's happening here
is and my son pointed that up you know a
couple of weeks ago I think it was where
he says you know you shouldn't use the
word irrational against people and he's
totally right there we're saying that
the theory is irrational we're putting
criteria for the theory but what do
people understand it oh what you're
saying is that I'm irrational and yeah
it's it's the second step this
projection this inference where where
you're saying look your theory is
irrational and the guy might say well
that's not my theory yeah I just
explained general relativity I don't
believe in it but then if the guy who
actually believes in any rational theory
you know you don't have to say it it's
just implied that he is also irrational
and that's where the big fistfights come
in my point is it's kind of like you're
doing it backwards because you're taking
the word irrational you're trying to
define it but really does nobody have
hold on but that's but that's kind of
backwards in a sense okay because the
word is the rat is irrelevant it doesn't
matter what word we're defining we're
just so we can use it we're just trying
yeah yeah yeah but it's it's irrelevant
because we're just trying to show that
the theories that we do call the
rational or a or dog have these four
conditions we're just trying to shine a
light on these four conditions the word
is is just it's just the shorthand
from then on once we understand what the
word what we mean by the word then it's
a shorthand from then on but we're
what's really important here are the
conditions the rules for losing a debate
or or or not making sense or what's the
best way to say irrational but as what
does but listen listen to something
there was what's-his-name Leonard
Susskind and he said look we had to
reinvent I don't know the exact word but
he said we have to reinvent what common
sense is so he used the term common
sense you can say
shanell or irrational sense we're all
referring to the same thing
now I can use the word blog or the
letter A and nobody will have any idea
what I'm talking about but when I say
rational people say oh you're redefine
your you're defining rational yes I am
I'm saying you gotta get used to what we
were gonna think about when we talk
about irrational theater a rational or
irrational theory but naturally and
that's where people start trembling
because they're saying oh you're saying
that my theory is irrational and now you
get a fight but if you say look I'm
gonna define dog and people say well dog
to me is something else
and we can go that with any word in the
dictionary you can say all garden Abel
you can make up words right yeah we can
mrs. Florrick yeah but then people will
say well what is that you know okay
we're gonna criteria you won't
understand but you gotta use it when I
read common sense my point today they
say well that you're just redefining
irrational to fit your needs well that's
besides the point because all were
asking is does your theory fit these
conditions forget the word right and so
there's no problem in using the word
rational for that matter as well now I'm
just saying the word is is it doesn't
matter just just basically what we're
saying is does your theory or does it
not fit these conditions okay get the
word okay we can call it a I mean that's
that's best important part the word
rational rational is like the cherry on
the cake it's just a qualifier it's just
to put it all under one heading what any
way you want to look at it I like the
word rational because it offends in a
way and sometimes you need to offend to
create that shot to get mad about autism
this is common sensical science or
common sensical physics and you know
again you have people like Susskind said
we had to reinvent what common sense is
he's doing the same thing he's just
doing he's saying look you know we're
doing here in mathematics we're looking
at quantum world we can't see it so we
created all these concepts that we move
around we had to reinvent what common
sensical means and i'm saying no you
don't go into irrationality into
uncommon sensical in
he uses that term he says we had to
invent uncommon sense so it's like he's
saying look we are irrational we are
uncommon sensical that's important
singers at the mathematician saying we
are uncommon sensical and I'm glad he
admitted that because it just shows that
you know they've gotten outside of
physics they in fact born said it in the
1920s 1927 or so on
he said max born and he said you know
physics has become more abstract and if
you look up the word abstract it's the
opposite of physical so they become less
physical physics and more abstract they
should call it you know the Department
of abstractions in Harvard or Cambridge
because that's what they do they do
absolutely they move abstractions they
don't move physical things anymore and
and so the question is yeah that's
uncommon sensical because I cannot
imagine you moving an abstraction a
concept that's where the problem comes
in and so they're not giving you a
physical interpretation for the real
world they're talking about their
abstractions which they created that the
you know in their blackboards some
concept that they created they say I'm
going to be moving you know this spirit
this energy this mass is this field you
know that's where the problem is and so
we have to define what rationality or
common sense is and yeah people are
gonna fight against that if it destroys
their their upbringing or what they've
been doing in the last hundred years
it's going to be there's gonna be
resistance to that change because it
goes to the foundations of what these
people are talking about anyways you
know so what is what are some of the
foundations of physics what are we
talking if physics is a branch of
science and I think nobody will
challenge that your physics is a branch
of science what are the foundations of
physics what do we need to do physics
and so I created a series of foundations
and they have to do a little bit with
what the mathematicians are gonna reject
as
semantics
but we need to establish what the
foundations of physics are and this has
nothing to do with ontology it's got
nothing to do with semantics it's got
nothing to do with my opinions it's got
to do with you can't do physics without
an object what are you going to be
moving if there are no objects in the
universe what are you going to be moving
what's what event is happening so it
goes to the root of what physics is
about you need objects that's the first
word that you you know that Sinek one
known word of physics you absolutely
need an object and that's not an opinion
it's just that you can't do physics
without it and you know I'm sure that
very few people will be able to justify
the opposite that you can do physics
without objects that's the first one so
so what I'm saying is you need to define
what an object is and here it is that
which is which has shape and then you go
through the list and you need to know
what distance is location what a concept
is to distinguish it from an object
motion and exist I'm saying these words
are seen akwonton
you absolutely need to define these
words these are the foundations of
physics okay and and again if you reject
these words any of these words and you
you need to be able to justify you know
where you got what why you disagree with
them and put something in this chain
because we got to do physics you got to
create the foundations of physics and
you know that's where you got to put
something in in its place you can't just
leave and say oh I destroyed your
proposal so I'm leaving no we got a chef
physics down otherwise okay so what is
an object and objects that which has
shape and here and people will criticize
that because they say oh that's also
your subjective opinion and here we can
see other proposals that are out there
that which we can see that yeah yeah
yeah
so that always makes sense yeah we kind
of need to know or have a consensus you
and whoever you're talking to the this
figment of quantum mechanics that we
keep invoking yeah we would have to have
to at least have consensus on what the
purpose of physics or science is before
before any of this would make sense but
okay but for now let's just take what do
you say is the purpose of physics or
science all this can make sense well the
purpose of physics is to explain
phenomenon in the real world and for
that that means we have to define what
we mean by real and and again real is a
synonym of exist and that's why that
word is in there because physics is the
science of existence physics only
studies or better still explains things
that exist or phenomena that occur in
real life you know physics doesn't deal
with Superman and Alice in Wonderland
falling into her rabbit hole physics
doesn't deal with that physics deals
with real phenomena and so forth in and
for that you need to define what real is
in this case we mean the word exists and
that's why that word was on that list
more importantly yeah the Cruzan
approximate all you said was the word
explain because if you're gonna explain
something forget about to yourself for
now to make it clear yeah when you want
to explain something to someone else
they have to understand what words
you're using what what what are the
words shorthand for basically what what
are what are these cuz every word is a
good like a byte of information and if
they're getting the wrong information
they're not gonna understand or they're
gonna understand something completely
wrong so all this that you're saying
with definitions for sure is important
if you want to explain something crisp
precisely and that's what you know what
I've done is I defined a word explain
what is an explanation by the way we did
not we don't rehearse these things we
revise here so I want you to know that
that's obvious that you know my Sunday
night's that I could rehearse this and
then we bring it on he just asked a
question I was ready because I knew the
discussion was going to go along that
line and so you know I do have these
props ready so what is explaining this
is my definition of explain it
I'm saying the causes in the case of
physics the reasons in the case of
philosophy and I'm saying that science
is divided into physics and philosophy
1d deals with causes the other one with
reasons and one deals with mechanism the
other one with purposes one deals with
objects and the other one with concepts
that's in general terms okay but here we
say what is explained we say the causes
or reasons underlying and phenomenon
okay we need to know or we're trying to
figure out what caused in the case of
physics that's what we're interested
here mainly what caused something to
happen what was the mechanism that
underlies it and the other the second
version of that of explain is the
prosecutors version of how or why a
consummated event happened and again
we're referring to mechanism what we're
saying how we're not saying there I'm
just gonna say oh the magician kept the
lady in half and he did it in 20 strokes
and he used the you know 15 seconds to
do it
we don't care about that's a description
we want to know how the trick is done
that's the difference and that's when we
say how or why we're referring to how
the magician did the trick and not what
actually just objectively happened on
stage okay so explain has to do with the
mechanism behind it and a synonym is to
theorize what do we mean by understand
and again this is not reversed I want
you to know here's understand that's my
version of understand to process a
series of images mentally to watch a
movie in the mind in other words your
mind is you're watching me you're
regurgitating some kind of movie you're
running the video inside your brain and
you're trying to make sense of it that's
what understand means second version of
that to rationalize or make sense of a
concept and the third one is to
faithfully reproduce or absorb the
prosecutors theory in your in one's own
mind to acknowledge communication okay
so if you did not understand you have
not yet acknowledged
you know the explanation what the
prosecutor was trying to get to you
and and and and that's the issue that
we've got here you know in these
definitions let me get this thing out
here we go
so so I try to provide definitions for
these words because they do come up in
discussions in debates people say what
did you mean by explain I thought I
explained no you did not explain how a
magnet attracts another you just said
positive attracts negative and that and
that's not an explanation that's a
description and you can understand the
description but you can the the issue in
physics is to understand the explanation
that cause the mechanism and that's why
we have to get into these definition
what do you mean by to explain what do
you mean by understand and sometimes the
words of ordinary speech or the
definitions of ordinary speech that you
find in the dictionary are insufficient
to deal with these matters you really
have to redefine this a little more
carefully because other people otherwise
people go you know off on tangents and
say well I thought I understood it well
I did understand and you're saying well
what did you understand you know if I
say I moved a wavefunction say I
understood what do you mean you
understood you moved the concept and you
understood no put it make a movie of it
and then you can show me that you did
understand reapeat regurgitate what what
the mechanic the the relativistic guy
said regurgitated but not verbally make
a movie of it show me tell me what you
did understand reproduce it it's crazy
we don't have precise definitions or
precision with definitions who's never
harped on and really any what do you
call it practice discipline any
discipline you know discipline that
comes to mind like that just jumps out
at me that really hurts
on the definitions of things maybe
linguist would disagree I don't they how
much but I don't know if they're more
interested in etymology from by the way
we have a question there by Martin I'll
keep that in mind
have you defined the foundations of
philosophy
the foundations of physics Martin all I
can tell you is I'm not into philosophy
and monkey has created I think a group
called rational philosophy I'm not in
that group I told them I don't want to
be in that group because I don't deal
with philosophy what do I mean by that I
mean that you know I'm not interested in
in analyzing things like love
consciousness information intelligence
I'm not interested in those subjects
personally and what are the reasons
maybe that I'm not interested in them is
that it's it's very opinionated maybe
and it's a lot more complicated or
complex than physic physics as objects
it's more objective but when you talk
about the mind and what should be and
love is this and that and we have this
theory of love and you have another
theory of love I think it can get quite
much more complicated than physics and
that's just my idea in general but in
more specific you know I'm not
interested in those subjects so I
haven't defined a foundation of
philosophy but I guess that's what that
group is for you go ahead and define it
and you know I I bless all of you you
know I'm into my whole world of physics
and I'm sufficiently happy with I've got
my hands full with that believe me so go
ahead and be fine and do what it what
you have to in the world of philosophy
and then come back and I'll be glad to
tear whatever you did a part you know to
challenge it or whatever but right now
I'm not so interested in that subject
and that's why I know the answer is no I
have not defined the the words the
foundations of philosophy I guess you
still need to define what you mean by
explain and and understand I think those
two words need to be in there you need
to define what a concept is right
because philosophy is gonna deal with
concepts you have to define what you
mean by reason and purpose
because that's essentially that realm
that's what the discipline does there
and so those are the words that you
would need to defined I have not defined
them okay I have not defined as far as I
know I don't know maybe I'll have to
look at the glossary in my book I tried
they're finding more what morality and I
still haven't finished it yeah morality
is another subject you know what is
moral and you got a million people out
there with different notions of what
morality is well because the I mean in a
nutshell real quick I want to go too
deep in it when you when you start
trying to come up with every possible
scenario and and you basically play kind
of a game of whack-a-mole we say okay
what about this you range throws you
saying what about this one allowance
moral you just kind of go with your gut
feeling oh why is it moral then you
throw out up another one okay that's
immoral why is that any more on that you
just kind of keep going through all
these yeah all the scenarios you think
and you have all these explanations of
just just to get to the definition what
why do I call this [ __ ] that anymore
right is killing nine is killing your
neighbor immoral well well if he killed
my brother
maybe it is moral maybe I'm justified I
have a reason to kill them vengeance or
whatever so if you just take it in the
absolute is it killing my neighbor
immoral and I'm saying well what are the
conditions if he killed my brother and
he assassin and you know maybe I don't
like that and that's why I took
vengeance so under those conditions
maybe it is moral but you know I guess
brings up an interesting point that we
haven't raised how much is how do I know
how do you show you're trying to define
a word right okay it's like you know the
definition you're just trying to put it
into words
ordinary speak no but I writing speech
is a gut thing just like I said when I
say okay why do I call this car or what
do I call this irrational and that
rational for example yeah so you already
it's like you're sure you're asking me
to say you're asking yourself and say I
already know your gut already knows like
if someone says call that irrational you
a definition yet someone will call this
I don't know
flying you know we don't he doesn't have
the specific word guys swimming it's a
[ __ ] yeah how's it flying when you have
the words kind of like in our soul or
whatever in our subconscious would've
intuitively we just don't have it
specifically so when you're trying to
find a word it's weird it's like you're
asking yourself okay what are all the
things that I would call this and then
you just try to find the criteria that
the least amount of criteria that fit
all those things that you would call
this smart kid isn't he and yeah I
define the word definition and that's
important too you need to define what a
definition is and I'm saying it's the I
don't remember the exact wording right
now but it's like you have it's it's you
reject what I said you put all kinds of
conditions okay so that you reject any
possibility of confusing that word with
something else and I give the example
which is a long an example because it
refers to objects but you'll get the
gist of it just by looking at this I say
it's white it has wings right and you
say well are you referring to a swan or
the White House because the White House
has wings too and so in order to reject
the the bird you say its ability and so
now you you restricted the definition
further and further and further until
there's no confusion when you say white
with wings at cetera etc and again that
refers to object but I guess it puts it
in the in the right context if you say
what is an object and the guy said well
it's uh you know that which has shape or
that which moves or that which I can see
or touch and you say well can you see
and touch space-time and the guy said
well no I can't so is that an object one
the intuitive defining doesn't right and
then you got to go deeper and deeper and
deeper so that you exclude and you
arrive at the word shape and that
exclude you know that's universal all
objects have shape and at the
rejects all other possibilities you
can't confuse it with that which you can
see or touch the thing about this
intuitive defining yeah is that I think
that's why people get into all these
discussions debates debates just not not
because because when when let's say we
have two people and they're trying to
die trying they're trying to talk about
the word life that's one of my favorite
ones cuz it's that's the one of the
heart islands up there with morality
okay you got the word life right and
they're both having a biological
discussion on something and what this
the intuitive this gets intuition has
life in this box this gets into it is
life in that box and we held there might
it's like a Venn diagram where a lot of
things overlap but some things this guy
is me in this case some is not the other
guy so it's like that's where they going
to knock because like know you're using
the word long or they go into this like
just just not but they don't understand
each other because this guy's
emphasizing some parts that the other of
that Venn diagram you know they do
coincide on some parts but there are
parts they don't coincide and so this
guy is saying oh no but you know I mean
with this word the word a I mean this
and the guy said oh no you don't know I
mean that's definitely not what this
means right right so they have my
notions of what it is and that's where
you have to kind of get to the vent part
of the the the the part that intersects
you got to get into the intersection
because and exclude all the others
because the others are only confusing
the issue of but that's not right the
real because that's that's agreement
that's agree yeah that's a green yeah
the way that you do it is it kind of
cuts through all that B's like oh it's
gonna take one of these circles we're
just gonna take one of these circles and
that guy's gonna hold the speech just so
we can understand them we're gonna
assume every any time you use this word
it's everything is falls into this
circle that way there's no confusion
absolutely good yeah and again what I'm
saying you got a fight you got a fight
for these definitions the guy has to
come one guy comes in and says this is
my definition
the other guy says this is my definition
and each one because they have different
religions different beliefs different
definitions they have to fight any get
and this guy's got to point out what's
wrong with this guy's definitions and
vice versa do they well they don't
because I know there you have two
different ones now we have the circle
and we have to bend diagram what you're
talking about right now is the Venn
diagram where they're both trying to
come to a consensus on the world no no
no not consensus not really consider no
damn party and no no and this is this is
what I pointed out that you've got at
least from my point of view you got
wrong from the other day we don't reach
agreements we do not sign a contract we
do not vote in science in science you
say look this is rationality these are
my condition these are my criteria the
other guy says I don't like them I don't
like that I rejected okay the conference
[Music]
more or less that's more or less I'm
along those nights let's listen
carefully here you have Christian and
you have a Muslim today agree do they
vote and they say okay let's put it so
let's put it to a vote let's see who's
right no that's not what they do these
guys continue doing Christianity these
guys continues doing you know Islam they
do not reach an agreement reached
consensus each one has its own religion
and so if you're going to go into the
Muslim world and you're a Christian
you're gonna argue with a Muslim he's
gonna say these are the rules over here
and you know what I don't like your
rules
okay then challenge them so you
challenge the rules or whatever and you
try to show that the other guy is
irrational or that he's got him wrong or
whatever
everybody's worse that the Muslim wants
to go into Christiana he's got abide by
their rules and so on and it's more or
less like that and I'm saying someone
comes into rational science do we say
well we're gonna try to accommodate you
as long as you put your money in the box
we're gonna be happy with you don't
don't leave our room we want you here no
that's not the way it works in science
the way it works in science
put up your you know put on your gloves
put up your dukes we're gonna fight and
the guy says you know I don't like your
criteria okay you don't like my criteria
what do you propose in its dead hold on
to that the context is extremely
important because and we're just doing a
presentation right then the guy can shut
up it's just that simple I'm about to do
a presentation I may use the word dog
and these this what I call dog okay it
doesn't matter what is opinion opinion
of the word dog is this how I'm using it
so that he can understand it fine
it's literally irrelevant if we're
talking about on that not a word that's
what I'm saying the context is important
because defining words for presentation
everyone shuts up we're just gonna take
my circle or make it shut up that's
simple
love it but gonna debate it gets weirder
because now if we're gonna use the same
words and it sit back and forth and now
we do need is some sort of consensus so
that we can both use the word so that we
can both understand each other again if
I mean oh no we don't need to compare
sorry just need you just need to know
what my definition is yeah but then it
gets kind of confusing using the same
word for with different definitions you
know yeah but I'm just as if I use the
word life for hey and use the word life
for be we might as well be using two
different words yeah and again and again
the only thing the only way we can
resolve that is there's a fight and the
fight doesn't doesn't really mean there
there is a consensus quite the counter
there's no consensus between the champ
and the Challenger or the or the
contender there's no consensus one guy
wins okay objectively on the state you
know on in the ring now what do we mean
by that in science we're saying someone
comes over and he's got his version of
science his version of how this universe
works and you have your version you have
the rational science version right and
you say okay these are my rules
the guy comes in he wants a fight he
says you guys are crazy you guys are you
know out of your minds okay you're small
nobody believes in you
irrelevant you don't care about that
these are our rules challenge the rules
first the guy you know before he starts
boxing he you know he's going to say you
know do I actually believe in
you know do I have an argument against
these criteria and if he can't challenge
that and you challenge and you ask him
okay what are yours and he says these
are my criteria for a rationality for
example so now we have a clash of
understanding or notions of what we mean
by rational this guy has his you know
this guy has black this guy has white
essentially right so so there's a class
there's a there's a fight there and so
now the each side has to criticize the
other side you say look this is what's
wrong with your side or what's
irrational or whatever about your side
that's why it won't fly and the other
guy has to do the same with yours and
and you know and again when you have
objective criteria like you can't use a
concept as an object and I don't know
what anyone can come up with against
that it doesn't even come to my mind
that someone could challenge that
criteria anything it sounds superfluous
Leo do I really have to mention that
right right it's like it's a self
self-evident right and so that I have a
problem with someone trying to reject
that for a theory again we're not
referring to the person we're saying a
theory that uses a concept as an object
is irrational and I'm not sure how
anyone can criticize that the guy can
say look I have another criteria okay
fine let's discuss that one and if we if
you can't find anything wrong but we'll
include it but that doesn't mean we've
got to reject the other one the other
one is a valid criteria as far as I'm
concerned and so if you're gonna say
look if we're gonna fight about science
these are my arguments that's what I'm
gonna take to the war to the battlefield
okay and the other guy says okay I'm
gonna bring my army fine let's fight and
if the guy can't figure out a way to
destroy your criterion that criterion
stays and vice versa if you can destroy
the other guy's criterion and the guy
just leaves the battlefield and says
well you know I don't agree with you and
I'm not gonna follow your rules well he
lost because he left the battlefield
because he can't answer your criticism
of his position okay that's what I'm
saying and and that's why we can do so
so it doesn't mean that the Christians
gonna become a Muslim or vice versa it
means this guy's gonna be a Muslim this
guy's gonna be a Christian and we're
gonna be rational
scientist and the mathematicians can do
all the weird stuff they do you know
we're not gonna have a consensus where
we say okay let's let's take it to a
vote no way this is not a voting issue
this is a question of let's fight let's
see what your arguments are and let's
see if they're rational and and I'm
gonna point out what your shortcomings
are and you got to point out what the
shortcomings are of what I'm proposing
and if you have no valid arguments I'm
I'm the champ objectively the champ yeah
and that's the way I look at this but
now I tell you sir Martin's you know I
don't have already answered oh yeah just
just how about that base again I have no
foundations for philosophy I'm just
saying that you need to define perhaps
reason purpose concept and explanation
and understanding I think those five
words should form some kind of
foundation maybe you have some more
words fine but I think those five are
like required okay I wanted to talk
about notions but notion is a very weird
world it's a very abstract word yeah but
it's it's a it's one we haven't talked
on I think it's very important okay why
do you why do you think it's important
first of all notions notion is
attraction hold on so definite it's a
synonym well concept notion the way I'm
using the word at least we're on the
same page okay is the definition of
award before you define it something
like that okay so it's a very it's a
definition okay it's like the
brainstorming session where we have a
definite we have a notion let's not say
definition we have a notion for love
right okay we all kind of are in the
ballpark somewhat okay
love is what the lion does with a
lioness that's love what does you have
you ever thought of notions cuz
essentially or trying to define a word I
mean not the not the other presentation
kind because the presentation kind of
cuts
everything it's very it's very bad about
debased and the debate senses that's
what their debate is about
they're okay they have completely
notions don't you have to first give a
presentation before you get into a
debate yeah but in the presentation
again they're both gonna have two
different circles fine that's that's
what now that's what now we have a
contrast with the yeah yeah obviously
but but essentially we're just keeping
your heads in the debate part okay
within the debate this guy has his
definition or notion of God let's just
take God from Issei okay
and the other guy's got his notion of
God everyone's got their own notion of
God like like we have an eight billion
circle Venn diagram on this notion of
God and we're also kind of trying to
cover as many of everyone else's yeah
well Shia cover is most common date it's
not a con understand each other well is
it to understand it yeah I mean it's
understand and make it so wide I'm
saying the definition is what is
restricted not what is wide if you make
it wide it's like well I don't want to
offend you so let's incorporate your
with the a billion day the circle
diagram it's more like four let's start
with what we all mean by this word isn't
that a good place to start
yeah okay you know what we're all trying
to do we're discussing these things
these guys are talking about God in this
case I love it but it's a bridge to like
it's like that's work that's at least
where to start what do we all mean by
the word love what do we all mean but or
even better what do we all not mean that
one's even easier well I think it all
not may not mean it's a long long list
but I don't like that but it's an easier
place to start me that's the easiest way
no but you say I think you said it right
we put the word notion and we're gonna
brainstorm now what what do you
understand by we look at the definition
the dictionary we listed maybe there's a
couple dictionaries out there they have
different definitions let's list them
all even internationally right right
yeah including international
and if if you know the language or you
translate using the google translator
now now the other person said you know I
don't agree with any of those or you
know I or he adds something to it he
says you know I have this other notion
of the word notion okay what is it and
we put it on so we list them and now we
find faults with different ones because
people say well you know if you use it
this way you we're gonna run into this
trouble the other guy says something
similar and so we start cutting down our
list it's no longer such a long list the
brainstorming can become shorter and
shorter you know because now there's
debate so the debate mates the
brainstorming shorter but it's weird but
but the but the shortening of the list
is the weird part because the shorter
you make the list the more the less
people agree you have agreed I don't
like the fight you don't like the fly
because it doesn't make sense in this
case it's not a fight okay because
you're not looking for a fight you're
just trying to figure out okay what does
he mean by the world we're not we're not
gonna come see eye-to-eye on this but
we're not gonna wait I'm not gonna
convince the other guy of anything and
it's not about convincing it's about you
what is argument you you use arguments
of why you can't use that word
consistently rationally scientific you
have such a wide range can have only
about because if the guy can't use it
consistently and you show that I guess
then you guys want to press that one in
from the board I would think but what
I'm trying to say is in a debate or even
just two people are talking they both
have their notions of a word and those
notions aren't gonna change
we're only defining the words so that we
can use both use the same word with the
same definition so that we don't get
into a knot no I don't think that's what
we're trying to at least that's other
way I look at it I'm saying objectively
can you use it consistently and the
other person says look let me point out
why or an example why
can't use that word consistently under
these conditions if you can show that
then the guy has to you know say okay
give me a reason why I should use it the
way you defined it if here I'm showing
you an example where it's used
inconsistently and then that's where you
run into trouble and and then your job
the guy who defends that definition the
onus is on him the ball isn't now in his
court to come up with an answer to that
question or to show why it he can use it
consistent you really need folks you
need a couple of yes charmeuse totally
in agreements the study of concepts
reasons and purpose in philosophy is the
study of concepts yeah and remember it's
it's also got to do with reasons and
purpose the way I look at it why because
I think under philosophy you have to do
some kind of explaining so it's not just
the study remember such a philosophy is
under science if right and you don't
have to agree with it but I'm saying
we're gonna put philosophy under science
you got to do some kind of expert
rationalization see right and and what
are you gonna explain well you can
explain concepts you can go into explain
love consciousness what was the one you
mentioned earlier life yeah you know you
can get into a lot of those concepts
that's one that's one branch the other
branch is you have to explain purposes
and reasons you know I use the example
of Napoleon whether you go to Waterloo
why did Caesar go to England you know
there's different opinions or different
rationalizations for that and that's
what you're also explaining I think
that's part of philosophy
it's your philosophy that this is your
explanation for the purpose or reason
that's what I'm saying that's how it
fits in there as I was saying before
that what I'm saying is I think you need
to make debate tutorials I think that's
what's missing to tourists missing on
the channel is at least one brightest
Sun in the world I have to listen to
what he says because
it's basically where you go toriel you
have to you know theoretical people Joey
and Bobby okay you give you you give an
example of a debate and you always and
and what and you kind of do a mock
debate and at every point you say okay
and this is where Johnny [ __ ] up you
know this is where Bobby messed up
because he didn't use the word
consistently or or you know just kind of
like it like you know you know why he's
just regurgitated he regurgitated
Galileo what did Galileo write he took
the wrote dialogue of two worlds right
and he put essentially you know the dumb
guy what was his name I had into a tip
of my tongue but anyways the dumb guy
represents the Catholic Church and the
smart guy he he represents the new wave
of people like Kepler and Galileo and so
on who say like Copernicus and so on
they say look you know you guys in the
Catholic Church you're defending the
wrong thing just because you're going by
scripture in our telescopes they're
telling us something different you know
we see and not only there is not more
than seven planets which are not
mentioned in the Bible because now we
found four moons at that time the
Galilean moons we found four moons going
around Jupiter but you know here we can
show that all these planets including
the earth go around the Sun and the
Catholic Church this you know just went
out of their minds because of this but
that's a dialogue it's a dialogue
between a rational person and an
irrational what simply seemed that was a
very simplistic more simplicity
something about simplicity
you know simplicity my point is it
doesn't have to be so hard he's more
just to show people where debates go
wrong you don't even have to make up one
you can take any debate off the you off
YouTube it goes off the rails and
literally point out look this is where
it could have not gone off the rails
because they didn't use the same word
consistently right here at this point
for the first time I now listen to my
son because I think he said something
very important you have a tutorial for
debates like the rule you know
or debating what is a rational debate
and for people to know at what point to
think at derail yeah and why did base
going circles or there's so many
questions there
and why ever several issues we have
Martin yar hold he says not a not a
question speaking of opinion and Phillip
philosophy
I've now pledged per month exactly the
amount of that Sweden taxes you if you
happen to odo it haha expand as that can
receive TV signals torsional ropes
yeah that's the energy that you're
getting you see you're paying for energy
hello Evan Shama how to make sense
really rationality is nothing but the
minimum requirements for actual sense
making yeah and and again we're kind of
going in circles remember you're saying
sense making and that's rationale and
it's like you're saying well rationality
is sense making yeah but that's like a
synonym
we kind of have to define it a little
more precise not yet fine we need
criteria criteria and that's what I'm
trying to do you know I've tried to put
criteria at least from a rational point
of view and someone's got to come up and
say look you're you're irrational
because of this or that or this is why
your criterion is not valid they have to
point that out to you and meanwhile you
can use that same criterion to throw to
overthrow whatever they proposed because
for sure if a mathematician confronts
you and you say look let me show you why
your stuff is irrational because you're
using concepts as objects first one
right and the guy what's what's the guy
gonna say no I mean what's he gonna say
oh whoa we spend the day moving concepts
at the lab you know I mean come on you
know so it's like he said at the
beginning it's self-evident
it's a self-evident criterion and it's
harder for the notion of rationale right
and it's gonna be very hard to debug
that one and people you know I want you
to know something I've written already
two or three articles in which I've
included that in in Cora and they don't
they don't have no one has come back
saying you're wrong because of this they
attack me personally fine that's great
but they have not attacked the criterion
because they they cannot what are they
gonna put four four you know you're
you're irrational and in using that card
ed criterion what are they gonna say no
they're gonna say you destroyed my
religion I don't like it that's that's
all they can say I mean the using
concepts as objects rule or condition
yeah really you think is at the center
of the eight billion circle Venn diagram
we're talking about the a billion
diagram of the word of the notion of
rationality or irrationality you think
that using concepts of objects is at
least a seven billion of those I agree I
agree everybody's got his own religion
and that's why we have to establish some
rules because we're having more people
on the planet and now all we're creating
is more Venn diagrams here creating more
more definitions more philosophies more
notions of motion by spite to what they
said about the least amount because
because they use the comments here the
rationality is nothing but the minimum
requirements for actual sense making and
like the minimum requirements part
because that also goes to definition
yeah where you're not trying to do a
strict yet well you know I'm not only
restricted you're trying to put the
least amount of conditions okay good it
separates it from every other word per
you're not trying to put like a billion
conditions doing this right and this and
if that and if the other no no it's just
chop it off make it make sure the the
word is crisp you know that the
definition is crisp and understandable
in that you know you don't have to agree
to it but if you don't agree with it
then you have to come up with an
alternative and and the first guy has to
challenge you and say well can you use
that consistently that's that's like an
objective way of testing the definition
say can use it over the objective mean
you can show that he does and the other
guy can show that you don't well then
you got a fight then you got you then
you got something to challenge some
something you can you know sink your
teeth into but if the guy just says well
I believe that this
my definition he's just giving you his
opinion he's doing religion and he's not
doing science and a great practice for
definition just as the cherry on top of
all this would be if you had a debate
with a computer literally takes your
different definitions okay let's put in
the computer let you fight against the
compete don't wait against me fight
against a computer it's just or you know
it's a nice um what do you call it like
like a brain teaser like like a thought
experiment
no no I'll give you the example on a
thought it's a thought experiment to
think anyone who's programmed anything -
who knows who knows how literally
computers take definitions let me give
you an example and what he just said the
mathematician programs the computer okay
here's the mathematician he says
particle so say you got a defined it so
the computer understands what particle
means he says wave function or a
probability wave and now he goes into a
sentence he says and we accelerated a
particle on the beam line and crashed it
inside that chamber
and so the computer says does not
compute he lost the computer says you
know it does not compute we got a
problem there I can't crash what is the
concept I can't accelerate what is the
concept so please redefine or you will
be exterminated in two seconds then and
the guy puts his life on the line that I
would love to see that if they're you
know if they're gonna say well all the
mathematicians at the math club we voted
for it if the computer doesn't care yeah
gotta be objectives that we don't care
how many people how many idiots voted
for addictive computers I think logic is
a nice word I gotta put that in the
computer because because logic takes
just that first the last man the comet
is rational
oh no then if you say that then we're
gonna have comments til the end of time
everybody's gonna try to be the last guy
[Laughter]
I don't know what it's time's up so
anyways we got to continue this tomorrow
but yeah you know we I think we have to
define what we mean by rationality and
it's not a question of agreeing and
reaching consensus it's a question of
someone comes into your store and he
wants a challenge and say that you are
irrational you are a silly person for
the beliefs you hold and what you do is
apply the definitions or the criterion
for ratio and say look this is where I
get my rationality that's what I
understand by rationality and you apply
them you know very objectively very um
very scientifically very consistently
and you challenge the other guy to say
well what's wrong with what I just said
and the other guy if he's gonna come at
you he can't come with again at homonyms
he's got to come in and say look this is
where your theory or your explanation or
your proposal fails and he's got to
point that out and obviously he's got to
bring his own stuff because you know we
got to have a solution for physics we
can't just say oh I destroyed your
religion and I'm going home no you got
to show me what you proposing instead
I'm the champ Dan says no you're not
because you're not the last one Martin
Martin has the last comment so I I gotta
say that he's the most rational guy
right oh now it's a gradient well see
you tomorrow folks and same time same
station we'll see you that bye bye